um by the trump campaign to uh to
undermine the outcome of this election
so
um first you know i just want to say we
are extremely proud and excited that joe
biden and kamala harris are now
president-elect biden and vice
president-elect harris
despite a global health pandemic 148
million americans the most
ever voted in this election and 75
million of them a record number
voted for biden and harris biden
rebuilt the blue wall winning michigan
wisconsin and pennsylvania
and we will win arizona and georgia when
the accounting is done there too
in fact i believe uh the advantage that
biden currently has in georgia is
actually larger than the advantage that
trump won michigan by in 2016.
uh so you know president-elect biden won
michigan
pennsylvania and nebraska two by larger
margins than trump did
in 2016. and that's because he assembled
the kind of broad and diverse coalition
we needed for a decisive win and to be
one of the only people in american
history to unseat an incumbent president
african-american and latino voters
suburban women
and independents fueled the
president-elect's clear win
over donald trump and so while you've
heard noise from trump and his allies
you know for example the republican
secretary of state in georgia
said the georgia election was
administered well the
republican chair of cobb county in
georgia called on state and national
leaders to respect the outcome of the
recent election and
quote transition in grace and of course
former president george w
bush called president-elect biden and
vice president-elect harris to
congratulate them
so this what we're seeing uh from the
trump campaign uh
is just that it is noise uh and in a
moment i'm gonna turn it over to bob who
will explain a little bit more about why
that is
but before i do i want to say clearly
and definitively that the american
people have spoken
in this election that our democracy and
the principles on which this country
is built are stronger than any attempt
to undermine them
and that joe biden who won more votes
than any president-elect in the history
of the united states will take the oath
of office on january 20th
2021 and so with that i'm going to hand
it over to bob bauer
to walk you through in a little more
detail thank you very much
kate and i am here today with our
general counsel dana remus
and i'm going to make a few opening
remarks and then
we'll take your questions the purpose of
the briefing today
is to put in perspective some of what
you're reading and hearing about
which is noise not really law
theatrics not really lawsuits and i want
to focus on
a few very specific issues number one
why these trump lawsuits are failing
around the country and will continue to
fail
i want to pick out a couple of specific
issues in the legal process that you
should be familiar with
any upcoming recounts and what they
might mean and particular arguments that
you're hearing from
the republicans certainly fraud most
notably but also
supposedly linked to this argument about
fraud the exclusion of observers from
polling places
and then i'll say a bit about the state
legislative activity that you may be
hearing about where i think there are
also
some significant misconceptions and when
i'm done i think you're going to find
out very quickly or you're going to
understand very quickly where the real
fraud
in this process actually lies but let me
begin by talking a little bit about the
lawsuits to date
just to give you an overall perspective
since you're reading that they're being
filed but the
disposition isn't always very clear
through
election day from june through election
day judges
have dismissed trump campaign lawsuits
in this election
against this election as utterly
unsupported by evidence that's
just from june through election day six
suits dismissed on that basis
since election day the pace has picked
up and judges have dismissed
another seven cases that the trump
campaign brought in these states georgia
michigan nevada and pennsylvania so
that's quite the one lost record
losing time after time now i want to
just go through a few of these to give
you a flavor for what we're talking
about
let's take for example six months ago to
go in the pre-election period and talk
about a trump campaign
effort to limit the ability of voters to
vote by mail including by
drop boxes and there the republicans
made their usual argument
that these drop boxes the use of these
drop boxes would lead to fraud
the judge who heard the case by the way
was a trump appointee
and he invited the campaign to come
forward with evidence
of course there was no such evidence and
i say of course because you'll see it
as a theme that runs throughout all
these cases
and he threw the case out saying that
the contentions the fraud related
contentions that the trump campaign made
were purely speculative and unsupported
by the evidence
this is a case by the way captioned very
specifically
donald j trump versus bokvar so this is
a trump campaign lawsuit
another lawsuit in new jersey that had
to do with ballots cast after election
day as provided for by the state
legislature
there too the judge threw it out finding
no evidence whatsoever
that the mail-in balloting program
adopted by new jersey would lead to
election
fraud including specifically no evidence
that the voter fraud would result from
ballots that were cast
after election day that there were such
voter fraud
resulting from votes cast after election
day
the trump campaign sued the montana vote
by mail system and again
a federal court throughout the suit and
here i think the rhetoric or
shall we say the measured comments of
the court deserve
quotation the court explained that it
was required to throw the suit out
because the trump campaign's
quote contention that the upcoming
election both nationally and
in montana will fall prey to widespread
fraud
is a fiction so the court dismissed it
as a fiction and again
this is a trump campaign lawsuit not a
party lawsuit donald j trump for
president
versus bullock and then the law trump
campaign
filed a lawsuit attacking uh expanded
vote by mail in the state of nevada
here too we have a judge appointed in
this instance by george w
bush he threw out the case also because
there was no evidence
only speculative far-fetched claims
about fraud
once again a case brought in the name of
donald trump's campaign committee
so what you have is one case after
another and this is just a sample
where the claims that they're bringing
amplified through press releases
including the fabled four seasons
landscaping
company press conference by rudy
giuliani
turns out to be completely meritless and
the courts recognize it as such
in fact and i just want to focus
everybody on what the trump campaign
says when they actually speak to a judge
versus what they say
in parking lots at press conferences in
a case in montgomery county in
pennsylvania
in a case in this case involved by the
way the question of
whether or not a ballot would be
invalidated for missing a signature
in a particular location or an address
in a particular location even though the
voter's address was readily identifiable
elsewhere
and the trump lawyers were actually
pressed on the question of whether they
were alleging fraud and so i just simply
want to give you the following from the
transcript
because this is what's taking place
inside the courthouse and not in the
parking lot
judge in your petition you don't claim
any of the voters committed any fraud
correct trump lawyer accusing someone of
fraud is a pretty big step we just want
to get the election done
trump judge i understand but i asked you
a specific question
and i'm looking for a specific answer
are you claiming fraud
trump lawyer to our knowledge at present
no
judge are you claiming any influence
trump lawyer
uh to our knowledge at present no judge
is that required to lodge that challenge
do you have to accompany your complaint
with an allegation of fraud
trump lawyer no it doesn't matter if
there was fraud
it doesn't matter if the mistake is a
big deal or not
so i think that's fairly telling very
different than what you're hearing of
course
in the parking lot now let's move
to the question that you've heard come
up repeatedly about observers and lack
of transparency
because observers were excluded or
limited in their access to the vote
count in polling places
let's be clear uh poland watchers
uh are credentialed they're identified
to the state
it is very easy to fact check this claim
and of course these chain claims have
been repeatedly fact checked
the republicans after all before the
election were bragging that they had
thousands and thousands of poll watchers
ready to go
and it was only after the election on
this sham allegation about transparency
that they claimed their poll watchers
were not permitted
to be included uh as a matter of fact
they were there in force in the same way
democratic appointed poll watchers were
to do what poll watchers are allowed to
do under the election code
and again in front of the judge rather
than in the parking lot
trump lawyers have admitted in cases
that had to be dismissed because of that
admission
that indeed they had paul watch was
present that was true in cases
in pennsylvania and also in michigan
as you know uh and kate mentioned this a
minute ago
the two current senators uh
in georgia unhappy about the runoffs
they were forced into
complain that the secretary of state had
not conducted a transparent process
and you can read what his response to
that was republicans attacking
republicans
on this bogus claim of lack of observer
access
simply untrue and easily verified on the
facts
two final comments many of you are aware
that uh there may be recounts
let's talk about what it means for there
to be a recount
one fact and one fact alone i think
might answer any question that you have
since 2000 in 31 statewide recounts
the average change in votes was 430
and the median change was 267
end of story these margins cannot be
overcome in recounts
so the recounts are yet another piece of
the political theatrics along with the
lawsuits being dismissed with their
claims of fraud
they shouldn't be taken to be a serious
challenge to the outcome of elections
of the election and they will fail as
such finally my last comment
uh before we take your questions has to
do with activity in the state
legislatures
some people are under the impression
that a state legislature
can not only hold hearings which
certainly can do and complain which it
certainly can do
but the state legislature
after providing for electors to be
selected by the popular vote
can after the election decide that
wasn't the way they should have gone
and on whatever ground they give they
have the constitutional right after the
fact retroactively to pick
electors uh who are committed to the
candidates who didn't win the election
with the voters that's simply not true
that's not in the constitution
that's not consistent with the
constitution and that will never happen
but i want to be clear that that's
another bit of
call it what you will puffery propaganda
that's being put out on the trump side
again it is very easy to establish that
it isn't true
so with those preliminary comments uh
dana and i would be glad to take your
questions
um all right um alex jaffe uh you have a
question feel free to unmute
thanks thanks guys for holding this call
um i wanted to ask bob you talked about
the
the theatrics of these moves are you at
all concerned that the
trump administration is pursuing legal
challenges to undermine
biden's transition and presidency and
how would you go about combating that um
yeah go ahead no but there's no question
since they can't overturn the outcome of
this election and joe biden will be
inaugurated
uh on january 20th 2021
that they are pursuing other if you will
collateral objectives and one of which
is
uh to attempt to instill in the minds of
some portion of the populace
uh that the election was illegitimate
and also to
under uh to throw obstacles in the path
of the government but the
biden-harris transition is going forward
it's moving along very briskly
president biden will take the oath of
august on january 20th 2021
and that's going to be our answer to
that i mean in the meantime there'll be
theater but it'll be playing to
increasingly light crowds until it
empties out completely and joe biden and
pamela harris
take their oath of office but i want to
pause for a minute and offer dana
an opportunity to comment as well yeah i
would just
uh add that the the presidential
transition act and act of congress
acknowledges how important the smooth
and effective transition between
administrations
is it lays out the process for the
transition
um and in it ensures that even as
the political process uh is
um in process producing a winner
that the government must rise above
politics and
ensure the best interests of the country
and so um
it has set forth uh the steps
um that both campaigns have taken over
the summer and take now that we have
a president-elect it governs um we trust
that it will guide the steps forward
and it will ensure that the president
and president-elect and vice
president-elect have
everything that they need um as bob said
uh they are moving forward they are
preparing to govern
um we have absolutely no worry or no
doubt
and that when they take office they will
be ready to go
we have yamiche next thanks so much for
taking my questions
i have a question it's a two-part
question the first is about the legal
strategy i know you said a lot of this
is just
noise but is there a legal strategy that
you would articulate about do you
are you gathering evidence on your end
and having to proactively
kind of get together and have a case
together
um so you talk a little bit about how
much time it's taking and then the
second thing i have is i know i've heard
bob say this a bunch of times which
and we've quoted you saying it's going
to be an embarrassment if they go to the
supreme court if it's impossible for
them to get
any sort of case to the supreme court
but at this point again do you see any
avenue for that no in the past what i've
said is they can push a case up to the
supreme court i don't know which one of
these losing cases they're going to
inflict on the supreme court but they
won't win it they won't overturn the
election
i was referring at some point to donald
trump saying we're going immediately to
the supreme court and i wasn't quite
sure
precisely how he intended to go
immediately to the supreme court
but if they have cases pending in
federal district court and they can
appeal them and then attempt to after
losing at the appellate level get the
supreme court to hear the case
but the embarrassment will be in the
quality of the case they bring and in
the certainty of the defeat that they're
going to face
as far as evidence is concerned um
they're the ones who are supposed to be
producing evidence we have the evidence
and it's in the form of 75 plus million
voters and counting
so that's our evidence our evidence is
the number of people who voted for joe
biden and the number of electoral votes
that he won
their evidence so far as i pointed out
by walking you through just a handful
of this material their evidence doesn't
exist
there's nothing they have to raise any
questions whatsoever
about this election in the legal process
thanks so much i would jump in and
just add to that um that i think an
important piece of this that we can't
lose sight of
is that it is thanks to experienced
uh and bipartisan officials and poll
workers across the country
that the election was put on so well
in a pandemic which is a herculean
effort and they
are hard at work finishing the count and
certifying the results
and that's how this process goes from
here so while
all of the noise is happening in the
courts
um the actual work of the next steps um
are on pace and uh
that is what will answer this that is
what what uh
decides um the election and has decided
the election
uh like bob said not the courts
that we have jeff mason next
jeff you may be on mute
i can't hear you
okay uh while we're waiting for jeff um
we'll go to jackie heinrich
thank you so much for taking my question
um my
question is what's your best guess at
why the gsa has delayed ascertainment
the law only says apparent winner
it doesn't stipulate the states must
have certified the results
have they given you a timeline for an
update and what are the legal options
that are on the table
if you can't elaborate on those options
can you point to any cases that might be
seen as a precedent or any legal text
that would apply
for somebody to judge how this is done
in the past they should look to the past
and with the exception of florida 2000
which is a very bad example
i think as you all know certainly not at
all analogous to this
situation the ascertainment as is called
would have been done by now now you read
press reports that indicate
that the white house is directing
agencies to
not cooperate in any transition i do not
know whether that's influencing the
behavior of the gsa
but i do want to emphasize that however
this develops
we can continue and are continuing with
the transition
these transmission meetings are taking
are ongoing they're progressing
there's no question that um whichever
route we travel here
we are going to be moving very quickly
and very decisively
uh toward a full transition that enables
the president-elect biden and vice
president-elect terrorists to assume
office
fully ready but i think if anybody wants
to
understand sort of what might be taking
place at gsa they should look at the
precedent and then measure it against
the behavior of the gsa to date
dana did you have anything to add to
that
i i don't have much to add to that uh i
think
that there's every indication from every
corner that
uh president trump his campaign his
allies
um are trying everything to interfere
with the inevitable but we
are pushing forward and we are confident
that the inevitable is
a very successful administration
um okay jeff are you able to uh unmute
yourself
okay we'll go to alexa course at the
wall street journal
hi um thanks for doing this i just
wanted to
um kind of ask another question about
state certification
a couple lawsuits the trump campaign has
filed
um specifically asking to halt or delay
certification you know what do you think
about
um you know their you know bids to kind
of slow down that process
and the claims they're making on you
know that part trying to attack that
part of the process
you'll see a lot of maneuvers like that
probably or
some maneuvers like that before the
election as you know state certification
requirements vary from state to state
the certifying officer varies from state
to state county certified the state
certifies
and so you know the trump campaign again
not with a view toward winning the
election which it can't
but with a view towards slowing things
up uh
may well work with its allies in the
various states to write a delay
certification we're not worried about it
i mean at the end of the day
you can perhaps create obstacles to the
smooth functioning of the process
but you can't end in the end of it when
all is said and done
you can't succeed in stopping the
process from coming to the inevitable
conclusion that dana just mentioned
so you know it's a procedural it's a
procedural maneuver that they may
attempt
but it's not going to have any effect on
the outcome
and i think it goes back to where bob
started
which is they simply have no evidence
and to succeed in a lawsuit that will
stop certification
there has to be evidence of a problem
with the process they have to come
forward with evidence
of fraud and problems uh which despite
multiple opportunities to do so they
have
been able to do so and so we are fully
prepared
for continued suits and continued
attempts
to create confusion and to do everything
they possibly can to slow
things um but at the end of the day
they have no evidence and thus they will
not be able
uh to uh stop this process
great that's all the time we have thank
you everybody for taking the time to
join us today
we look forward to continuing to work
with you through a successful
biden-harris transition and into a
successful biden-harris administration
thank you very much we'll talk to you
soon thank you
are we back in the holding room
nope hang on bob okay
bob there's still some reporters in here
but we are uh
down off platforms
jennifer and matt thank you so much
great job
we'll see you next time
you